İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 16 Aralık 2024 Pazartesi 48. Ders günümüz saat 19.33 kamerayla ilgili bir problem vardı.
Onu uzatmaya çalıştım. Dersimize başlıyoruz. Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Arkadaşlar en son kaldığımız yer Stude Bind genel fonksiyon adaptörüydü.
Aslına bakarsanız modern C++'dan önce Bind'ın yerine kullanılan 6-7 tane ayrı adaptör vardı.
Bind First, Bind Second gibi isimlerini anmak istemiyorum.
Çünkü bunlar önce depreket edildi sonra tamamen hilden kaldırıldı.
Onun yerine sadece Stude Bind geldi.
Yani şimdi modern C++'ın şu andaki durumuna bakarsak Stude Bind'la beraber iki tane daha adaptörümüz var.
Birini gördük. Not FN. Diğeri de arkadaşlar Mem FN. Bugünkü derste göreceğiz.
Şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Stude Bind'la herhangi bir Colable'ı sarmalıyoruz.
Fakat Stude Bind bize bir Function Object döndürüyor.
O Function Object'in fonksiyon çağrı operatörü fonksiyonunu çağırdığımızda değerli arkadaşlar aslında bir şekilde gönderdiğimiz Colable'ın fonksiyon çağrı operatörü fonksiyonunu adapte edecek şekilde çağırıyor.
Burada hemen hatırlayalım.
Başlık dosyamız Functional'dı.
Functional'da geçen dersimizde Reference Wrapper sınıfını, Not FN adaptörünü gördük.
En son Bind fonksiyon adaptöründe kalmıştık.
Arkadaşlar Bind üstünde biraz daha durmak istiyorum.
Ondan sonra Mem FN'ye geçişe sonra da Stude Function sınıfını göreceğiz.
Şimdi önce geçen dersi bir hatırlayalım.
Burada tuhaf bir şekilde isimlendirilmiş sabitler var.
Underscore 1, underscore 2.
Ancak bu sabitler nerede arkadaşlar?
Arkadaşlar Placeholders Namespace'i içinde.
Dolayısıyla normalde bunları şöyle kullanmamız gerekiyor.
Stude Placeholders'ın underscore 1'i.
Ama örneğin ben en azından zaman kazanmak için, her defasında isim alanı ismini yazmamak için, üretimde bu iyi bir şey anlamında söylemiyorum.
Örneğin STD için using direktifi kullanabilirim ve değerli arkadaşlar yine STD Namespace'i içindeki Placeholders Namespace'i içinde yine dirersem ne kullanabilirim?
Arkadaşlar bir using direktifi kullanabilirim.
Herhangi bir callable'ı sarmalayabiliriz demiştik.
Bu callable örneğin bir closure object da olabilir.
Mesela auto f add eşittir.
Tabi buradaki lambda ifadesi capture clause'a da sahip olabilir şimdilik olmasın.
int a int b int c return a artı b artı c elimde böyle bir callable var.
Şimdi şunu yazabilir miyim?
Stude Bind birinci parametre her zaman callable'dı.
Efendim f add diğer parametreler bu fonksiyona gönderilecek argümanlar.
Örneğin şöyle yazarsam underscore 1 underscore 2 ve 0.
Bu durumda fonksiyona gönderilen argüman arkadaşlar birinci argüman geri dönüş değeri olan callable'ın birinci parametresine gönderilen argüman f add'in birinci parametresine, ikinci parametresine gönderilen argüman f add'in ikinci parametresine ama üçüncü parametresine de sıfır değeri gönderilecek.
İster doğrudan bu fonksiyonu şöyle çağırabilirim.
Bu da legal değil mi?
Çünkü geri dönüş değeri olan function object fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunun operanda oluyor.
Böyle de çağırabilirim.
Hiçbir engel yok.
Örneğin fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini yazdırayım.
Ya da geri dönüş değeri olan function object'i de bir başka nesneye taşıyabilirim.
Yani şöyle de yazabilirim değil mi?
Örneğin stutbind
f add
arkadaşlar
bu sefer şöyle yapalım.
f add'in
ikinci parametreyi
underscore 2
sadece göstermek için değişen bir şey olmayacak toplam olduğu için
underscore
ya da 10
ve
underscore 1
geri dönüş değerini
bir değişkende saklayalım.
Örneğin çok anlamlı olmasa da.
Ve şimdi fonksiyona iki tane argüman göndereceğim.
Eğer şöyle yazsaydım
fonksiyona sadece bir argüman gönderecektim.
Ve gerçekten de fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini
bir argüman göndererek yazdıralım arkadaşlar.
Buraya kadar geçen dersimizde gayet güzel gördük.
Ama şimdi biraz daha ilerleyelim.
Burada örnekte tek farklı nokta
soluble olarak kullandığım
varlığın bir lambda ifadesinden elde edilen closure object olması.
Ama
kendi
function objectim de olabilirdi.
Mesela bakınız
class
funktör.
Arkadaşlar
efendim
class'ın bir tane nesi olsun?
fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonu olsun.
void
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
iki tane parametresi olsun.
int x int y
kans göğe fonksiyonu olsun.
Ve
klasik a ve b'nin
değerlerini yazdıralım.
suit
c out
arkadaşlar
köşeli parantez
a
virgül
a değil x
x
virgül
y
böyle bir fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonu var.
Şimdi
suit bind
bu sefer birinci parametresine
kendi
funktör
objectimi
argüman olarak veriyorum.
Diyelim ki
ilk parametreye
gönderecek argümana
aynın geri dönüş değeri olan
function olacak
ama
ikinci argümana
20 değeri
bağlanacak.
Yine
placeholders
namespace'i
ve
elde edeyim
callable'ı
yine
f isimli
bir değişkende
saklayayım
ve fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonu çağırayım.
f
boyut fonksiyonu olduğu için
arkadaşlar
bir geri dönüş
değeri yok.
Şimdi bir şeye dikkat ediniz.
Neden
syntax hatası
gösteriyor?
Evet
evet
söyleyin bakalım
neden
syntax hatası
gösteriyor?
Çünkü
bakalım
iki tane
parametremiz var.
f
ismini verdik
bind
bir syntax hatası da
görebildi mi?
Tamam
anlaşıldı değil mi?
Bu
private
olmuş.
Evet
sizden önce gördüm
bu sefer
abstract olmadığı için
private olmuş
şimdi
syntax hatası
gitti.
Arkadaşlar
üye fonksiyonu da olabilir.
Hocam doğrudan fonksiyonu çağırmak yerine neden böyle yapıyoruz anlayamadım.
Geçen derste görmüştük aslında.
Söyleyeyim bir yiğit.
fonksiyonu adapte edip
onu
başka bir yerde başka bir amaçla kullanmak için.
Örneğin algoritmalar.
Sanırım
geçen hafta yazdığımız örneklerin bir kısmını
gözden kaçırmış olabilirsiniz.
Orayı anlattım çünkü
en tipik kullanımı
algoritmalara
geçmek.
Algoritmaların
istediği
kolubulu
elimizdeki bir kolubulu
adapte ederek
oluşturmak.
Mesela en tipik örnek.
İsterseniz bir örnek daha yapalım yiğit.
Orası pekizsin.
Olur mu?
Sadece yiğit pay için değil
bütün arkadaşlar için.
Bak çok basit bir örnek.
Vektör başlık dosyamı dahil ettim.
Vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
random fill
yüz
ve
arkadaşlar
irant
sıfır
bin
on bin
şimdi
diyelim ki
bir algoritma
kullanacağım.
Olsan diyor ki
birçok
code
libde
callback
mandı
yazılıyor
bakış
açısı
olması açısından.
Arkadaşlar
zaten bu da
bir callback.
Yani sonuçta
ben
bir fonksiyon
ama
genelleştirilmiş
bir callback
olarak
biz daha çok
stod function'ı da
kullanıyoruz.
onu da birazdan göreceğiz.
Merak etmeyin
ben kullanıldığı
bütün temaları
anlatacağım.
Ama
Oğuzhan Bey'in
dediği doğru
tabii.
O amaçları da
kullanıyor.
Bakın bakın şimdi
mesela
bu vektör üstünde
ben şöyle bir işlem
yapmak istiyorum.
Diyelim ki
belirli bir değerim var.
int n
hatta onu da
standart input'tan
girelim.
Bir
tam sayı
yerin.
efendim
stod
seeing
n
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
E şimdi
benim elimde örneğin
var olan
standart kütüphanenin
callable'ları var.
Standart
function
objektler var.
Örneğin
stod
less
greater
gibi
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Ya da
stod
plus gibi.
Arkadaşlar
mesela
stod
plus'ı düşünün
plus
iki parametreye
sahip
bir
function
objekt.
Yani bunun
fonksiyon çağırma
operatör fonksiyonu
iki tane parametreye
sahip.
Ama ben
diyelim ki
bir algoritmada
konteynerdaki
öğelerin
arkadaşlar
hepsini
belirli bir
tam sayıla
toplamak
istiyorum.
Ama
bu durumda
eğer
o
algoritma
range'deki
öğeyi
fonksiyona
gönderiyorsa
o zaman
bir parametreli
fonksiyona
ihtiyaç var.
Bir parametreli
kolumla
ihtiyacımız var.
Ama ben
plus'ı
kullanmak
istiyorum.
O zaman
plus'ı
iki parametreli
bir fonksiyon
olmaktan
çıkartıp
arkadaşlar
tek parametreli
bir fonksiyon
haline
getirebilirim.
Mesela
transform algoritmasını
düşünün.
Transform
algoritmin
başlık dosyasını
ekleyelim.
Transform'un
iki tane
nesi vardı?
Overload'u
vardı.
Ben
Unary Function
isleyen
Overload'unu
kullanayım.
Yani
IVEC BEGIN
IVEC END
Arkadaşlar
IVEC BEGIN
Şimdi şöyle yazsam
olur mu?
Plus
Neden
olmaz?
Çünkü
plus
iki tane
parametreye
sahip
fakat
transform algoritması
bu
Overload
bu rençteki
öğeleri
bir
parametreye
sahip bir
fonksiyona
argüman olarak
gönderiyor.
O zaman
benim
örneğin
plus'ı
kullanmam için
bir şekilde
adapte edip
tek parametreyle
çağrılan
tek argümanla
bir
callable
haline
getirmem
gerekiyor.
Bunun için
bind'ı
kullanabilir miyim?
Bind'ın
birinci
parametresine
plus'ı
argüman olarak
versam
arkadaşlar
ikinci
parametresine
izleyin
ikinci
parametresine
efendim
diyelim ki
underscore
biri
argüman olarak
versem
buraya da
değerini
versem
arkadaşlar
ne yapmaya
çalıştığımızı
anladınız mı?
Anlamayanlar için
hemen kısa bir
açıklama yapalım.
Bind
bize
bir
function
object
döndürecek
bu
function
object
daha önce
söylediklerimi
tekrar etmeyeceğim
tek bir
argümanla
çağrılacak
o zaman
zaten
transform'da
bu range'deki
öğeleri
tek argümanla
çağrılacak
bir
callable
göndermiyor mu?
Aslında ben
transform'a
bind'ın
geri dönüş
değeri olan
function
object'i
argüman olarak
veriyorum.
Yani
temaların
hepsinde
ister
callback
amaçlı
kullanın
ister
algoritmalara
gönderin
temaların
hepsinde
bir
adaptasyon
söz konusu.
Zaten
bind'in
yaptığı
bu.
Evet.
Ama
biz şimdi
kullanım olanaklarının
tamamını
görmedik.
Biraz daha
bind'de
işimiz var.
Evet,
evet.
Şimdi
vektörümüzü
print edelim
arkadaşlar.
Hatta
şöyle
yapalım.
Tam
göründüğü
yüz
olsun
gönderdiğim
argüman.
ve burada
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şu soru
başka.
Necati
bind'le
yaptığımız
her şeyi
lambda
ifadeleriyle
yapabilir
miyiz?
Her şeyi
demeyelim ama
çok
şeyi
lambda
ifadeleriyle
yapabiliriz.
Ne zaman
lambda
ifadesi
kullanalım?
Ne zaman
standard
function
object
kullanalım?
Ne zaman
bind'i
kullanalım?
O konu
hakkında
baya bir
konuşmak
gerekiyor.
Ama
şimdi
değil.
efendim
yüz
tane
yerine
siz
görün
diye
on
tane
öy
olsun
transform'u
çağırmadan
önce
range'i
yazdıralım.
Arkadaşlar
yani
bakın
her yerde
kullanabilirim.
Başka bir örnek
daha.
Mesela
burada bir
fonksiyon
olsaydı
bu fonksiyon
benden
yazdırılacak
değeri
ve de
yazdırılacak
değeri
içine
alan
parantez
küme
parantezi
açısal
parantez
gibi
öy
alsaydı
normalde
iki parametreyle
ya da üç parametreyle
çağrılan bir fonksiyon
olacaktı.
Ama ben
tek parametreli
fonksiyon isteyen
callable isteyen
bir algoritmaya
onu doğrudan
gönderemeyecektim.
dolayısıyla
onu ya bir
lambda ifadesiyle
adapte edecektim
arkadaşlar
ya da
bindle
kullanacaktım.
Neyse efendim
yazdıralım bir
jprint
ivek
bu işlemden
sonra
tekrar
jprint
ivek
derleyip çalıştırıyorum.
Bir tam sayı
girin
ama
onu kullanmamışız ki
onu da kullanalım.
Şuraya
en iyi
yazacaktım.
Evet.
Yoksa neden
bir giriş alayım?
Bir tam sayı
girin
yüz
arkadaşlar
bakın
bütün öy
evlere
git
yüzle
topladım.
Ama bu işi
yapmak için
zaten
elimde var olan
bir
kolubulu
kullandım.
Bu örnekte
bind
iki parametreli
bir
kolubulu
bir parametreli
bir
kolubula
dönüştürdü.
Çünkü
transform'ın
istediği
benden
bir parametreli
bir
kolubulu
tam tersinde
yapabilirdim.
Değil mi?
Evet.
Evet bu
güzel bir örnek.
Şimdi devam
edelim.
Arkadaşlar
bind
sınıfların
üye fonksiyonlarıyla
da kullanılabilir.
Mesela
illa
kolubu
derken
free
function
olma
zorunluluğu
yok.
Mesela
şöyle bir
sınıf
olsun.
Class
My
Bu
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonları
olsun.
Boy
full
int
arkadaşlar
hatta
parametresi
olmasın.
bak
çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir yazı
yazdıralım.
My
Class'ın
bu
isimli
fonksiyonu.
Bir
tane daha
fonksiyon
var
x eşittir
x
hadi
bir tane daha
olsun.
Şurayı
düzeltelim.
bas
fonksiyonu
int x
bu örneği özellikle
dikkatle izlemeye
çalışın.
int x
int y
x
eşittir
y
süper.
Şimdi bakın
main
fonksiyonu
Play
Solders
My
Class
değil mi
sanıp
anıyorsanız
My Class
türünden
bir
object
m
şimdi
bind'ı
çağırıyorum.
Sputbind
birinci
parametre
callable
bu da
bir
callable
My
Class'ın
efendim
full
fonksiyonu
çok
bir katrizi
arkadaşlar
ama
My
Class'ın
full
fonksiyonu
sınıfın
üye
fonksiyonu
parametre
değişkeni
yok
ama
bir
sınıf
nesnesi
için
çağrılmalı.
İşte bu durumda
bind'de
kullanırken
arkadaşlar
en azından
bir sınıf
nesnesini
alması lazım.
Dolayısıyla
buraya
underscore
yazdım.
Geri dönüş
değerine
bakın
auto
f
örnekleri
çok dikkatli
takip etmeye
çalışın.
Anlamadığınız
yeri tekrar
etmemi
isteyin.
Şimdi
tahmin edin
f'i nasıl
çağıracağım?
f'i
şöyle
çağıracağım
arkadaşlar
f
m
çünkü
yıldız
nesnesi
bu sefer
birinci argüman
olarak
gidecek.
Görüyorsunuz
değil mi?
Şu
full fonksiyonunun
gizli parametre
değişkenine
gönderilecek
aslında
nesne
burada
doğrudan
gördüğünüz gibi
m nesnesi
derliyorum
ve çalıştırıyorum.
Gördüğünüz gibi
çalıştı.
Arkadaşlar
eğer şöyle
yazsaydım
izleyin
my class
bu
değil de
hadi bakalım
ikinci bir örnek
auto
f2
şimdi
bara bakın
barın bir tane
parametresi var
stutbind
adres
my class'ın
barı
underscore
bir
arkadaşlar
nesne
için
underscore
iki
bu da
argüman için
eğer bu
şekilde yazarsam
isterseniz
birincisinin
yorum satırına
alalım
onu zaten
gördük
auto f
şimdi fonksiyonu
şöyle çağıracağım
f
m
on
ama bakın
ne yapabilirdim
birinci
parametreye
m'yi
bağlayıp
ikinci
parametreye
arkadaşlar
underscore
bir
deseydim
şimdi
f'i
bu şekilde
çağırsaydım
bu durumda
m nesnesine
bağlamış
olacaktım
ama
argüman olarak da
10 değerini
göndermiş
olacaktım
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
gördünüz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir de
baza bakalım
bu sefer
auto f
eşittir
goodbind
adres
my class'ın
bas fonksiyonu
bas fonksiyonunun
iki tane
parametresi var
underscore
bir
iki
underscore
üç
eğer böyle
olsaydı
o zaman
fonksiyonu
şöyle
çağıracaktım
m
runtime'a
her defasında
dikkatli
bakınız
değerli arkadaşlar
evet
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
bakın
my class
intik
seconds
x
eğer
burada
ben
m'nin de
adresini
yazdırsaydım
o nesne için
çağrıldığını
görecektiniz
ama şimdi
bakınız
izleyin
bu sefer
birinci
argüman olarak
m'yi
bağladım
ikinci
argüman olarak
arkadaşlar
20'yi
bağladım
ve buraya da
underscore
1 dedim
şimdi
fonksiyonu
nasıl çağıracağım
tek argümanla
çağıracağım
f
böylece
my class'ın
bas fonksiyonu
da
yıldız dizi
olarak
m nesnesine
ve
20 ve
argümanlara da
arkadaşlar
neleri
gönderecek
sırasıyla
20 ve
50 değerlerini
gönderecek
gördük mü
arkadaşlar
bir de
referans
semantiğine
dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor
geçen dersi
anlatmıştım
ama orayı
bir kez daha
başka bir örnekle
göstereyim
mesela şöyle bir
fonksiyon olsaydı
void punk
intref
a
b
intref
c
a
b
c
artı artı
eşittir
int
y
eşittir
int
z
eşittir
ve
x'in
y'nin
z'nin
değerlerini
yazdırıyorum
şimdi
bind'e
çağırıyorum
bank
x
y
z
argümanı
kullandırdım
geri dönüş
değerine
bir nesne
de sakladım
ve şimdi
fonksiyonu
çağırdım
e
r
x
y
ve z
yazdırdım
burada
nesnelerin
değeri
değişmeyecek
çünkü
bind
kendi
veri
elemanlarına
aslında
fonksiyona
gönderiyor
yani
fonksiyona
gönderilen
x
y
ve z
z'nin
kendisi
değil
aslında
fonksiyonu
adapte ederken
bunların
kopyasını
çıkartıyor
dolayısıyla
bakın
fonksiyonu
çağırdım
x
y
ve z
değişmedi
ama
reference
wrapper
kullansaydım
ref x
ref y
ref z
durum değişecekti
gördüğünüz gibi
şimdi
arttı
arkadaşlar
hakim edebildik mi
evet
mesela
başka bir örnek daha
algoritmalarla ilgili
az önce
Yiğit Bey'in
sorduğu
soruyla ilgili
arkadaşlar
bazı nesnelerin
de zaten
kopyalama yoluyla
aktarılması
mümkün değil
geçen derste
şöyle bir örnek
yazmıştım
studo stream
ref
efendim
bir fonksiyon
olsun
myprint
birinci
parametresi
studo stream
ref
ve ondan sonra
arkadaşlar
o stream
ve bu
x ve y'yi
yazdırsın
os
hatta
aynı nesneye
döndürsün
return
os
x
i
borçluk
y
find
myprint
see out
arkadaşlar
ve
diyelim ki
underscore
bir
iki
auto
f
görüyor musunuz
evet
şimdi
f
değerliyorum
sentax
hatası
neden
sentax
hatası
çünkü
myprint
fonksiyonu
arka planda
function
object'i
oluştururken
gönderdiğim
argümanları
kopyalıyor
ama
o stream
sınıfı
copyable
değil
dolayısıyla
böyle durumlarda
referans
semantiği ile
geçmek için
arkadaşlar
ne yapmanız
gerekiyor
ref
sarmalayıcısını
kullanmanız
gerekiyor
yani
reference
reproluk
durmanız
gerekiyor
şimdi
bind'in
birinci
parametresine
argümanı
geçerken
ref
sarmalayıcısıyla
sarmalayacağım
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonu
yazmamışım
evet
yanlış yere
yazmışım
ref
myprint'i
siyah
evet
şimdi
az önceki
sentax
hatası
olmayacak
başka bir
sentax
hatası
yok
gördünüz mü
yani
bazı
nesneler
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapalı
işte
yine örnek
unique
ptr
sınıfı
olsaydı
thread
sınıfı
olsaydı
bunlar
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapalı
evet
şimdi
bind'den
yeterince
bahsettik
üye fonksiyonları
da kullanabileceğimizi
gördük
arkadaşlar
geriye bir tek
memfn kaldı
bakın şimdi
memfn
ismi nereden geliyor
member function
buraya dikkat
memfn ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
memfn
sizden
parametre olarak
bir
sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunu
istiyor
arkadaşlar
ve
o üye fonksiyonu
adapte ediyor
bir örnek verelim
mesela
klas
my klas
public
memfn'nin
kullanım alanı
daha fazla
belki
arkadaşlar
basit bir şey
yine
lambda ifadesiyle
de yapabilirdik
void funk
önce memfn'nin
ne yaptığını
iyi bir şekilde
anlamaya çalışalım
cast
ya da void
who
cast
ve çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir yazı
yazdıralım
yine
my klas
who
bir de
int parametreli
fonksiyonu
olsun
int x
ve
arkadaşlar
x eşittir
x
buraya kadar
takip edebildik
umarım
şimdi
elimde
my klas
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne var
my klas
m
hatta
elimde
bir de
otro
ptr
dinamik
ömürlü
bir nesne var
yani bir
pointer var
my klas
m nesnenin
kendisi
ptr'de
bir nesneyi
gösteren
pointer
elite
ptr'yi de
şimdiden
yazalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi
memfn'yi
kullanıyorum
memfn
adı nereden
geliyor
member
function
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonundan
adresini istiyor
örneğin
my klas
arkadaşlar
punk
fonksiyonu
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
adres
my klas
funk
değildi
bu
o yüzden
aldım
çizdi
bu
ve
memfn'den
aldığım
geri dönüş
değerini
bir değişken
de saklayayım
auto
f
eşit
bir
functional
mı silindi
hayır
niye altını
çiziyor
evet
memfn
yine private
mi oldu
o da değil
bakalım hataya
evet
küme parantezi
bir şey mi eksik
min
my klas
noktalı virgül
bakalım
menfn'e
my klas
who
hangi eklememişim
nesneyi
evet
f
bir dakika
my klas
who
bir yerde
bir yanlışlık var
basit bir yanlışlık
biraz bekleteceğim
who
parametresi yok
iki tane
ikisi de
who olmuş
şunları önce
bir
değiştirelim
tamam
bitti
ben görmedim
ikisine de
who ismini
vermişim
farklı bir hata
var mı
yok
anlaşıldı
değil mi
iki ponsiyona da
who ismini
verdiğimi
unuttum
arkadaşlar
şimdi ben
e-ponsiyonunu
buraya dikkat
my klas
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneyle
çağırdığımda
buradaki
adaptör
yani
memfn adaptörünün
geri döndürdüğü
callable
aslında
bu üye fonksiyonu
sarmaladı ya
ne yapacak
bu nesne için
bu üye fonksiyonu
çağıracak
bakın çok çok önemli
tekrar ediyorum
memfn
bana tıpkı
bind gibi
tıpkı
notfn gibi
bir
function object
verdi
fakat bu
function objectin
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatörünü
bu sınıf
nesnesiyle
my klas
sınıf nesnesiyle
çağırdığımda
o da
bu sınıf nesnesi için
sarmalanan
fonksiyonu
çağıracak
böylece
ben
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunu
sanki üye fonksiyonu
değil de
bir free
function
açılmışçasına
çağırma
şansına
sahip oldum
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
üstelik
bu
template olduğu için
adres
gönderirsem
yine kendi
ayarlıyor
yani örneğin
ifi
ptr ile
çağırsaydım
yine aynı şey
bu seferde
ptr'nin
gösterdiği
sınıf nesnesi için
yapılacaktı
yani
nesnenin
kendisini de
gönderebilirim
ya da
arkadaşlar
ne de
gönderebilirim
nesnenin
adresini de
gönderebilirim
derliyorum
ama şimdi bakın
örneği biraz değiştirelim
bu sefer
var fonksiyonuna
gelelim
oto
p2
eşittir
ya da onu silelim
yorum satırına
alalım
otof
eşittir
memfn
adres
myclass
foo
şimdi yine aynı şeyi yapacağım
ama bu sefer
foo'nun tek bir
parametresi olduğu için
memfn'nin geri döndürdüğü
colable'a çağrı yaparken
arkadaşlar
ben de
sınıf nesnesiyle beraber
bir argüman daha göndereceğim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
foo demişim
var olacaktı
diğer fonksiyondan bahsediyorum
bakın
şimdi başlangıçta bu
anlamsız olabilir
ama tahmin edin
kullanıldığı tipik yer
neresi
arkadaşlar
kullanıldığı tipik yer
algoritmalar
yine
arkadaşlar
bazı algoritmalar
ne yapıyor
bir range'deki
öğeleri
bir
colable'a gönderiyor
ama ben
range'deki öğeleri
colable'a gönderirken
colable olarak doğrudan bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunu kullanamam
ama mem fn'nin geri dönüş
değeri olan adaptörü
kullanabilirim
burayı anladınız mı
evet
bakın en basit örneği
izleyin
for each algoritması
şimdi önce for each algoritmasını bir hatırlayın
for each
algoritma
açık dosyası
polis ne yapıyor
bir range'deki öğeleri
bir colable'a
argüman olarak gönderiyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama şimdi ben
colable olarak
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunun çağrılmasını istiyorum
hatta
gelin basitle bir sınıf oluşturalım
plastik
plus
net
basit bir int sarmalayıcısı
sınıfı olsun
public
net
arkadaşlar
efendim
konstruktor
int x
bir tane default
konstruktor olsun
im
mx
x
mesela bu sınıfın print isimli bir fonksiyonu olsun
void print
arkaçlar
const
bu sınıfın
increment isimli bir fonksiyonu olsun
print fonksiyonu değeri yazdırsın
hatta
neyse bir boşluk versin
bakın şimdi
bir konteynerim olsun
vektörün
net
açılımı
dediğimiz
evet
back görün
net açılımı
my back
arkadaşlar
initializer risk
kontraktörü
kullanayım
net
önemli olan basit bir örnek oluşturmak
şimdi for each'i çağırıyorum
for each
my back
begin
and
lambda ifadesi kullanmaya ve alternatif olarak
memfene
adres
ne için
print fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar şimdi memfene'nin döndürdüğü adaptör
aldığı sınıf nesnesi için
o sınıf nesnesinin print fonksiyonunu çağıracak değil mi
e
konteynerdaki üveylerde
bu range'deki üveylerde
ne nesneleri olduğuna göre
bu range'deki üveylerin hepsi için
ne çağırılacak
print fonksiyonu çağırılacak
runtime'a bakın
diyeceksiniz ki şimdi
ama Necati ben bunu şöyle de yapabilirim
zaten başka şekilde yapamayız demedim ki
şöyle de yapabilirdim değil mi
memfene'yi hiç kullanmazdım
bir lambda ifadesi
alırdım
lambda ifadesinde
fonksiyonun parametresini
efendim
const
match
ref
yapardım
bu lambda da
arkadaşlar
artık
ister
ne'nin print fonksiyonu çağırsın
böyle de yazabilirdim
takip edebildik mi
evet
ne'nin printi
aynı iş olurdu
yani bazı durumlarda
karar vermekte zor olabilir
bunun trade off'unu yapmak
okunabilirik açısından
efendim
memfene adaptörünü mü kullanayım
yoksa
lambda ifadesi mi kullanayım
aslında bu
adaptörlerin
hepsi için olmasa da
çoğu için
geçerli bir soru
tekrar derleyip çalıştırıyorum
ya da şu örneğe bakın
for each
myvegbegin
myvegend
adres
ne'nin
inkrementi
bu sefer de
arkadaşlar
ne yapacak
evet bir yerde bir hata var
myvegnech
adres
ne'nin
inkrementi
void
inkrement
üveyleri
post yapmışım
yok orada bir problem yok
for each
myvegbegin
myvegend
memfene'yi
kullanmamışım ki
siz de söylemiyorsunuz
ben de diyorum
niye sentaksat alacak
işte
memfene'yi
ne için
inkrement fonksiyonunun
adresini
argümanı olarak
verdim
böylece
sınıf nesnelerinin
hepsi için
neyi çağırdı
arkadaşlar
emiran çelik
memfene ile
stud function
arasındaki
farkları
iyi ayırt edemedim
bambaşka varlıklar
emiran
stud function
henüz anlatmadım
ama
stud function
bir
callable
sarmalayıcısı
stud function
arkadaşlar
bir kere
bir fonksiyon
değil
bakın
memfene
bir fonksiyon
stud function
ise
bir sınıf
birazdan
stud function'a da
gideceğiz
merak etmeyin
ama
memfene ile
stud function
arasındaki
farkı
bırakalım
bence
çok benzer
yapılar da
değil
memfene
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunu
alıyor
size bir
callable
veriyor
siz
memfene'nin
verdiği
callable'a
o üye fonksiyona
sahip
sınıf türünden
bir nesne
arkadaşlar
ya da bir
pointer ile
çağrı yaptığınızda
o nesne için
sarmalanan
üye fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasını
sağlıyorsunuz
fakat
stud function
bir
genelleştirilmiş
callback
yapısı
bir sınıf
bir callable'ı
sarmalıyor
ve siz
stud function'un
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
arkadaşlar
o
callable'ın
çağrılmasını
sağlıyor
belki şu yönden
emir an
benzetmiş
olabilirsiniz
memfene'nin
geri dönüş
değeri
bir
function
object
ama
stud function'ın
kendisi zaten
bir
function
object
stud function
belirli bir
parametrik yapıda
template argümanı ile
belirlenen
bir callable'ı
sarmalıyor
isterseniz onu
bugün onu da
göreceğiz
stud function'ı
bırakalım
birazdan
konu başlığımız
stud function
olacak
memfene'yi
anladık mı
bakın memfene için
bir örnek daha
yapalım
izleyin
arkadaşlar
bakın
vektörün
string açılımı
string başlık
dosyasını da
ekleyelim
svec
random fill
yirmi
random name
j print
svec
bekleyin biraz
evet
örneğin copy algoritması
bakın şimdi
copy
birinci ve ikinci
parametresine
iteratörle
geçilen
range'deki
öğeleri
üçüncü parametreye
gönderilen
iteratör konumundan
başlayarak
yazıyor
değil mi
kesinlikle
böyle kadar
okey mi
evet
ama şimdi
ben
copy'yi
çok iyi dinleyin
öyle bir şekilde
kullanacağım ki
emiram
bu vektördeki
öğelerin
uzunluklarını
dirence yazacak
hadi bakalım
vektörün
size t açılımı
türünden
lenvec
svec'in
size'ı
şimdi ben
vektördeki
öğelerin
stringlerin
length
uzunluk değerlerini
arkadaşlar
lenvec isimli
vektöre
kopyalamak istiyorum
şimdi bunu
neyle yapabilirim
a
bir
lambda
ifadesiyle
yapabilirim
iki
memfneyle
yapabilirim
ikisini de
gösterelim
lambda
ifadesini
anlamak
biraz daha
kolay olduğu için
önce
lambda
ifadesine
bakalım
copy
arkadaşlar
izleyin
evet
biliyorsunuz
birinci parametre
ikinci parametre
ve
copy diyorum
transform
özür dilerim
şimdi bakın
transform
algoritması
ne yapıyor
birinci
ikinci parametresiyle
verilen range'i
range'deki öğeleri
bir fonksiyona gönderiyor
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
değerini
iteratör konumuna yazıyor
copy iyi bir örnek
değil
transform daha güzel örnek
ama şimdi bakın
ne yapacağım
svec begin
svec end
a
lenvec begin
şimdi
collable olarak
bir
lambda ifadesi
kullanayım
lambda
const
st
string
refs
arkadaşlar
return
s in
length
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
böylece
ne yapacak
transform
algoritması
bu range'deki
öğeleri
bu fonksiyona gönderecek
bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerinde
arkadaşlar
lenvec
vektörüne yazacak
kopyalayacak
c print
lenvec
ifet hilal
sevim
görüyorsunuz
yazıların uzunluğu
pek şöyle yapabilir miydim
burada
memfne'yi
kullansam
memfne'ye
arkadaşlar
stringin
lenvec
fonksiyonunun
adresini
versin
bu durumda
range'deki
öğeler bu
collable'a
gönderildiğinde
bu
collable'da
yani memfne'nin
geri dönüş
değeri olan
collable'da
aslında
aldığı nesne
için
sınıfın
lenvec fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
aradaki
farka rağmen
aynı işin
yapıldığını
anladınız mı
sanırım
anladınız
gördünüz mü
yine aynı iş
yapıldı
işte memfne'de
böyle bir
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon adaptörü
o zaman hemen
emran bey'in
sorusunun
cevabı olan
stud function'a
gelelim
arkadaşlar
önce şunu
anlamanızı
istiyorum
bakınız
şimdiye kadar
gördüğümüz
gerek
stud bind
notfne
gerek
memfne
bunlar
fonksiyon
yani fonksiyon
şablonu
ama bu fonksiyon
şablonları
emran ne döndürüyor
collable döndürüyor
yani function
object döndürüyor
yani ben
ister
bind olsun
memfne olsun
ister
notfne olsun
bunları çağırdığım
zaman
bunlardan geri dönüş
değeri olarak
bir function
object alıyorum
o function
objecti
fonksiyon
çağırı
operatörünün
operanda yapıyorum
ama o function
object de bir şekilde
aslında
benim
fonksiyon adaptörüne
gönderdiğim
fonksiyonu
bir şekilde çağırıyor
buraya kadar
zaten net olarak
anlaşıldı
ama stud function
böyle değil
stud function
aneta
bir fonksiyonu
sarmalıyor
bir collable
ama neden
sarmalıyor
daha sonra
başka bir yerde
çağırmak için
yani örneğin
siz bir
collable
doğrudan
çağırmak
yerine
onu bir
stud function
nesnesiyle
tutarsanız
o stud function
nesnesine
bir fonksiyonu
argüman olarak
gönderebilirsiniz
bir sınıfın
veri elemanı
yapabilirsiniz
bir sürü
olanaktan
faydalanabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyonun
parametresini
o zaman
bir function
pointer
yapmak yerine
bir stud function
nesnesi
yapabilir miyim
işte az önce
Oğuzhan Bey'in
söylediği
durum bu
yani daha çok
buna yakışıyor
bir fonksiyonun
parametresini
stud function
yapacağım
böylece onu
bir callback
olarak kullanacağım
ama şimdi
stud function'ın
normal bir
function pointer'a
göre
avantajı ne
bir function pointer
belirli bir
parametrik yapıdaki
fonksiyonun
adresini tutabilir
ama stud function
bir sınıf
şablonu olduğu
için
belirli bir
parametrik yapıda
herhangi bir
colable'ı
sarmalayabilir
yani bu
colable
gerçekten bir
fonksiyon
olabilir
bir fonksiyon
adresi
olabilir
bir function
object
olabilir
bind'dan
elde edilmiş
olabilir
efendim
bir closure
type olabilir
o zaman
nasıl çalışıyor
bir bakalım
stud function
bir
arkadaşlar
sınıf
bakınız
stud
function
arkadaşlar
bu bir
sınıf
şablonu
dolayısıyla
bakınız
sınıf
şablonu
bizden
bir fonksiyon
türünü
argüman
olarak
istiyor
ben
vakti
zamanında
eskiler böyle
diyor ya
ben vakti
zamanında
sizi bu
konuyu
hazırlamak
için
function
type ile
pointer
type
arasındaki
farkı
anlatmıştım
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
olsun
int
u
hatırlıyor
musunuz
bakalım
bunları
c'de de
anlatmış
oluyorum
aslında
u'nun
türü
ne
diye
sorduklarında
ne
demelisiniz
cevap
öğretmenin
fon'un
türü
function
type
öyle gösterilmiyor
yiğit
şöyle gösteriliyor
int
anlaşıldı mı
ama
bakın
bu fon'un
türü
fon'un
kendi
türü
ama fon'un
adresinin
türü
o tür
bu
fon'un
adresinin
türü
neden
bunu
söylüyorum
bravo
çağrı
function
pointer
takip
dincisi
stut
function
sizden
bir fonksiyon
türünü
template
argümanı
olarak
istiyor
o fonksiyon
türünden
bir fonksiyonu
sarmalıyor
bir kolabalı
yani
örneğin
siz şöyle
kullanacaksınız
function'un
int
açılımı
eşit
f
eşittir
u
böylece
bakın
u'yu
f
sarmalamış
oluyor
şu an bir fonksiyon
çağrısı falan
yok
hikaye
şu
siz bir
stut
function
nesnesiyle
bu örnekle
görüldüğü gibi
bir kolabalı
sarmalıyorsunuz
rest
to function'ın
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
sarmaladığınız
fonksiyon
çağrılıyor
şimdi hangi fonksiyon
çağrılacak
arkadaşlar
full fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
hatta fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
yazdıralım
cout
ve
bu fonksiyon da
şöyle bir fonksiyon
olsun
int x
arkadaşlar
izleyin
return
net olarak
anlayın diye
x şartlı 2
any function
bakın
derledim
çalıştırıyorum
gördünüz mü
ama şimdi
birkaç tane
önemli özelliğe
dikkat
sit adın
ne kadar önemli
olduğunu görün
arkadaşlar
burada
full
stut function
bir sınıf
olduğuna göre
ben de
burada
stut function
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturduğuma göre
buradaki
full'yu
aslında
stut function'ın
konstruktörüne
argüman olarak
gönderiyorum
değil mi
en az bir
evet cevabı
bekliyorum
evet
teşekkür ederim
peki
sit ad ne
demekti
sınıf
şablonunda
konstruktör'a
gönderilen
argümandan
hareketle
arkadaşlar
template
parametresi
ya da
parametrelerine
karşılık gelen
argümanların
çıkarımının
yapılması
o zaman
c plus plus
17'de
17 ve
sonrasında
sanki
stut function
bir
sınıf şablonu
değil de
bir sınıfmış
non-templetmiş
gibi
22.
satırdaki gibi
nesne
oluşturabilir miyim
cevap
evet
burayı anladık mı
dolayısıyla
bakınız
izleyin
arkadaşlar
fu gibi
fonksiyonlar
olsun
emran neye
hayır
dediniz
anlamadım
anlamında
mı
tamam
tekrar anlatayım
emran
sitat diye
bir özellikten
bahsettim
o derse
katıldığınızı
varsayıyorum
eğer katılmadıysanız
anlaşılması için
benim sitat hakkında
tamam
peki
son cümle
sadece
burada
function
bir sınıf
f de
function
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
dolayısıyla
burada
fu'yu
function
sınıf
şablonundaki
konstruktora
argüman
olarak gönderiyorum
bu durumda
derleyici
konstruktora
gönderilen
argümanın
türünün
ne olduğuna
bakarak
template
argümanı
olarak
hangi türün
kullanılacağının
çıkarımını
yapıyor
buna
sitat deniyor
yani
eğer
sitat
olmasaydı
c++
öncesinde
olsaydı
ben
template
argümanını
ekspresit
olarak
yazmak
zorunda
kalacaktım
emran
ama şimdi
onu yazma
zorunluluğum
yok
onu
derleyicinin
çıkarımına
bırakabiliyorum
anlaşıldı
mı
ya da
belki
ben
sizin tam
olarak
ne sorduğunuzu
anlamamış olabilirim
anlaşıldıysa
tamam
süper
arkadaşlar
bakın
mesela
int dönen
full
float dönmeye
başlasaydı
bir kere
int dönen
full
float dönmez
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
static
compile time
da belli olur
yani böyle
bir fonksiyon
float
döndürmez
anlaşıldı mı
ve
eğer siz
stod
function'a
sorunuz
şuysa
uygun
olmayan
türden
bir
argümanla
onu
konstrakt
etmeye
çalışsanız
arkadaşlar
bakın
mesela
full
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
float
full
fonksiyonunun
parametresi
float
doğru bir iş
yapmamış
olacaktınız
zaten
sentaks hatası
olacaktı
anlaşıldı mı
ya da
duruma göre
bir dönüşüm
olacaktı
evet
burası anlaşıldı mı
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
runtime
da değişmez
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türünü
türünün ne
olduğu
derleme
zamanına
ilişkin
bir bilgidir
ama şimdi
şuna
bakınız
int
bu
bir örnek
int int
bakın
int
bar
int int
int
arkadaşlar
bas
int int
strat
neç
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
int x
int y
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
int
şimdi şunu
göstermek istiyorum
bakınız
bu sefer
fonksiyonların
imzası
değişti
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
int
parametreler
de int
şimdi
strut function'a
bakınız
function
şöyle yapmak
yerine
arkadaşlar
int
parantez
int int
açısal parantez
f1
eşittir
fu
sitada
bakarak
f1 eşittir
function f1 eşittir
fu yazabilirim
function f2 eşittir
function f3 eşittir
efendim bar
ya da bas
yazabilirim
olabilirim
ama onların hepsinin
parantez
dikkat ediniz
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
daha
işimiz
stut function'la
epey
olacak
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi
stut function'ın
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
örneğin
f1'in
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
ilgili argümanları
geçtiğimde
bu da
neyin çağrılmasını
sağlayacak
Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusu
hocam
kullandığımız
bir live içinde
info
olan
funk
daha sonra
flood
funk
olduysa
client
kodda
sitat ile
alınması
undefined
behavior
yaratmaz
mı
yaratır
duruma göre
sentaks hatası
olabilir
duruma göre
undefined
behavior
olabilir
fonksiyonların
parametrik yapısının
ne olduğuna
bağlı olarak
oraya doğru
ilerliyoruz
şimdi önce
ben soruyu
anlamamış
olabilirim
o yüzden
sorunun
tekrar edilmesini
istedim
ama isterseniz
bana biraz
müsaade edin
ben hepsini
anlatayım
eksik kalan
bir yer
varsa
oraya
sorarsınız
çünkü
soracağınız
soruların
çoğu
zaten
önümüzdeki
15-20 dakika
içinde
benim
anlatacağım
öğeler
önce makro
düzeyde
konuyu
iyi
anlamamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
yani
şimdi
ayrıntılardan
ziyade
önce makro
düzeyde
bir konuyu
kavramaya
çalışın
ondan sonra
ben sizin
sorularınızın
hepsine cevap
veririm
merak etmeyin
şimdi
önce şunu
anlamanızı
istiyorum
stut
function
ne yapıyor
bir
kolu
sarmalıyor
stut
function
funksiyon çağrı
operatörü
fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
sarmalanan
kolu
balı
verdiğiniz argümanlarına
çağırıyor
bu ne işe yarıyor
bir fonksiyonu
adeta
bir sınıf
nesnesine
bağlı olarak
tutuyorsunuz
sarmalıyorsunuz
depoluyorsunuz
ama dilediğiniz
başka bir yerde
başka bir zaman
başka bir fonksiyonun içinde
o kolu
bunun
çağrılmasını
sağlıyorsunuz
fakat şimdi
stut function'ın
diyeceksiniz ki
buraya kadar
function pointer
da işimi
görürdü
fakat
buraya kadar
function pointer
işinizi
görürdü
ama
function pointer
sadece
fonksiyon adresini
tutabilir
ama şimdi
aradaki
farka bakın
farkı çok net
anlayacaksınız
izleyin
o parametrik yapıda
herhangi bir
kolubulun
adresini
kolubulu
sarmalayabilir
dedim
bakın bakın
stut function
ya da
using direktifini
kullanayım
function'ın
int
int açılımı
arkadaşlar
bir neyse
bu arada
stut function
default constructible
fakat
default construct
denilen bir
stut function
nesnesi
henüz
bir kolubulu
sarmalamamış
durumda
dolayısıyla
fonksiyon çağırı
operatörünü
çağırmamalısınız
hatta
burayı da bir
anlatalım
aradan
çıksın
arkadaşlar
bir stut function
nesnesi
empty
durumda
olabilir
yani
herhangi bir
fonksiyonu
sarmalamamış
durumdadır
stakededir
ya da
bir fonksiyona
sahiptir
bir kolubula
eğer
boş durumda
ise
fonksiyon
çağırı
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
standart
kütüphanenin
stut exception
sınıfından
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilmiş
arkadaşlar
bad function
call
türünden
bir exception
throw ediyor
önce bunu
bir görelim
mesela
şu anda
f
boş durumda
mı
cevap
evet
herhangi bir
şekilde
ne kendisine
bir atama
yaptım
ne de
arkadaşlar
constructor'ına
argüman olarak
bir fonksiyon
verdim
şu anda
boş durumda
ve
if'i
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatörünü
operanda yaptım
ne olacak
undefined
behavior
değil
exception
throw
edecek
izleyin
burada
gönderilen
exception'ın
türü
arkadaşlar
stut bad
function
call
yani
bunu
kendi
türünden
bir
hata
exception
parametresi
catch
ile
yakalayabilirdi
stut
bad
function
call
evet
peki
burası
anlaşıldı mı
önce temel
noktaları
bir anlayalım
ondan sonra
bütün sorularınıza
cevap verin
merak etmeyin
arkadaşlar
peki
boş olup olmadığını
sınayabiliyor muyum
evet
sınıfın
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonu
var
bakınız
sınıfın
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonu
adı üstünde
boğul
değer döndürüyor
eğer
arkadaşlar
doluysa
true döndürüyor
boşsa
false döndürüyor
yani
bu demek ki
exception
true etmesini
istemiyorsanız
stut function
nesnesine
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
operanda yapacaksanız
bu durumda
önce
dolu
olduğundan
emin
olmalısınız
yani şöyle bir
kon
if
f
see out
ya da şöyle diyelim
if f
f
auto
red
eşittir
f 12
ve
see out
red
ama
boşsa da
boş olduğunu
yazdıralım
see out
if
doesn't
have
a
function
ya da
kolum
evet
bazen biraz acele ettiğimiz için
karşılar yerine oturmuyor
eğer sorular biraz daha geç gelirse
çok daha iyi anlaşacak
görüyorsunuz
bakın
f doesn't have a
kolum
ama şimdi
int
bu
int x
return
x şarpı
x artı
ister
sonradan akama yapın
arkadaşlar
f eşittir
bu
bakın
kolumla
initialize edebileceğiniz gibi
construct edebileceğiniz gibi
atama da yapabilirsiniz
f eşittir
foo
şimdi durum değişti
bakın
if'in doğru kısmına girdi
buraya anladık mı
operatör
bool fonksiyonuyla
bir
stut function
nesnesinin
bir kolumla
sahip olup olmadığını
ya da belki
şöyle bir terim daha uygun olabilir
boş olup olmadığını
sınayabiliyorsunuz
operatör
bool fonksiyonu
true değer döndürürse
kolum
bir kolumla
sahip
stut function
no discard
gibi
attribütler
geçirilebiliyor mu
hayır
çünkü
no discard
bir fonksiyonu
niteliyor
arkadaşlar
eğer
bir değişikliği
falan yapmadıysa
hayır
ama
yine de
yani çok sıradışı
bir soru gibi
geldi bana
no discard
mantıklı da
olabilir aslında
hani
standarda bakmak
gerekiyor
no discard
aslında şöyle
demek gerekiyor
belki
ben soruyu
anladım
şöyle yazarsam
no discard
attribütünü
buraya koyarsam
soruyu ben
biraz değiştirerek
sorayım
bu
no discard
yapacaksa
bu
no discard
function
object
de geçiyor
mu
yani örneğin
f
bu şekilde
fonksiyonu
çağırdığımda
bakın herhangi bir şekilde
derdi hiç
uyarı vermedi
ama bir de
ilginç bir soru
no discard
arkadaşlar
şurada
kullanmaya
çalışalım
normalde
no discard
bakın burada
error verdi
ama bazen
no discard
yeri de
değişebiliyor
şurada
kullanalım
yine
error
yani no discard
bu şekilde
kullanımı
yalnız bakın
şu derleyiciye
bağlı olabilir
yani belki de
başka bir
derleyicide
denersek
sizin dediğiniz
değil de
onun
syntax hatası
olması gerektiğini
söyledim
yanılmadığımda
ama şurada
belki
derleyiciye
bağlı olarak
no discard
attributunu
buraya da
propagate
edebilirdi
evet ilginç
peki devam
edelim şimdi
o zaman
şuraya kadar
geldi
boş olabilir
dolu olabilir
boşken
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
arkadaşlar
exception
throw ediyor
bad
function
koltüründen
doluysa
fonksiyon
çağrılıyor
boş mu
dolu mu
olduğunu
operatör
bull
fonksiyonuyla
ne yapabiliyorum
test
edebiliyorum
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şimdi
asıl
önemli olan
kısma
gelelim
herhangi bir
kolubılı
sarmalıyor
kritik nokta
burası
bu fonksiyonu
kalsın
ama
gelin
bakın
burada
bir lambda
ifadesi
oluşturalım
function
çok dikkatli
izlemenizi
istiyorum
int
f
bakın şimdi
f eşittir
full
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sentars
satansı var mı
yok
auto
ptr
eşittir
adres
full
ptr bu durumda
bir function
boyudur
acaba
f eşittir
ptr
diyebilir miyim
bakın
burada da
bir sentars
hatası yok
devam
f eşittir
m a
değil
f eşittir
lambda
int x
int y
return
arkadaşlar
x
artı
y
çarpı
fonksiyonların
ne iş yaptığı
önemli değil
arkadaşlar
buradaki
fonksiyonda
izleyin
tek parametreliymiş
buradaki fonksiyonda
yine
parametresi
int
geri dönüş değeri
int olan bir fonksiyon
değil mi
o zaman
buradaki fonksiyonda
yine
kime
operant
atanabilir
bizim function
nesnemize atanabilir
ya da ilk değer
olarak verilebilir
izleyin
devam
hatta
bir function
object
bakın bakın
bakın
struct
punct
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
int x
const
int
return
x
çarpı
x çarpı
x
arkadaşlar
her birinde
galvan fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini yazdırayım
şu anda boş
t out
f
on
şu anda
sarmaladığı fonksiyon
full fonksiyonu
olduğu için
arkadaşlar
değerini
döndürecek
eğer yanlış
hesaplamadıysam
evet
yanlış yerde
yazmışım
evet
oto ptr
eşittir adres
bu
şurası
f eşittir
bu
şurası
özür dilerim
evet
bakın
şunu kapatalım
şimdi
fptr'yi atadık
tekrar
kolu
bulu
çağırıyorum
yine 105
ama bakın
lambda ifadesini
atadık
yine aynı
argümanla
kolu
bulu
yani
stup
function'ın
sarmaladığı
kolu
bulu
çağırıyorum
olmalı
değil mi
ama şimdi
bakın
arkadaşlar
ptr
türünden
mini esne
atıyorum
f eşittir
ptr
yine
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum
takip edebildik mi
ya da şuna
ne dersiniz
int bar
int x
int y
int z
return
x çarpı
y artı z
bakın
arkadaşlar
f eşittir
bind
fonksiyonun
ismi
bar
underscore
bir
tabi
place
oldur
namespace'i
normalde
bu üç
parametreyle
çağırılan
fonksiyon
değil mi
underscore
bir
ne olsun
şimdi
bind'in
geri dönüş
değeri
bir
function
object
mi
o
function
object
çağırı
operatör
fonksiyonunun
parametresi
int
mi
geri dönüş
değeri
int
mi
o zaman
bind'in
geri dönüş
değeri olan
stut
function'ı
f'e atamamda
herhangi bir
sorun var mı
yok
o zaman
f'i
yine
çağırdığımda
o zaman
function
sarmalanan
fonksiyon
bu argümanlarla
çağırılacak
değil mi
gördünüz mü
evet
şimdi
diyeceksiniz ki
tamam
buraya kadar
anladık
herhangi bir
pola
bunu sarmalıyor
peki
nerelerde
kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
ooo
nerelerde
kullanabilirim
bir numaralı
kullanım alanı
all
back
arkadaşlar
call back'in ne olduğunu
herkesin bildiğini
varsayıyorum
bir fonksiyona
bir fonksiyonu
çağırtma
mekanizması
öyle değil mi
mesela
c kodu
yazıyor
olsaydık
fu isimli
bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
bu fonksiyonun
ikinci parametresi
bir function
pointer
olsaydı
biz bu fonksiyonun
kodu içinde
bir yerde
şöyle bir kod
yazsaydık
tabi c'de
auto yok ama
auto
y
eşittir
pp
x
aslında
burada
bu fonksiyonun
ikinci parametresine
adresi gönderilen
fonksiyonu
çağırmış olacaktık
değil mi
yani
call back
mekanizması
bu arada
call back
hem mekanizmaya
hem de
böyle bir fonksiyona
argüman olarak
gönderilen
adresi gönderilen
fonksiyona da
verilen terim
böylece
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyonun
hangi fonksiyonu
çağıracağını
fonksiyonu
çağıracak olan
kod belirliyor
işte
standart
q sort
fonksiyonunu
hatırlayın
c'nin
standart
kütüphanesindeki
ya da c'nin
standart
kütüphanesindeki
b sort
fonksiyonunu
hatırlayın
bunlar dışarıdan
call back
istiyorlar
hatırladınız mı
evet
ya da
at exit
fonksiyonunu
hatırlayın
dışarıdan bir
call back
istiyor
bir fonksiyon
adresi istiyor
ama şimdi
böyle yapmak
yerine
ben fonksiyonun
parametresine
bir function
pointer
yapmak yerine
doğrudan
stut function
yapabilirim
türünden
bir referans
da olabilir
tabi bu arada
türeş ismi
vermek
iyi bir fikir
olabilir
duruma göre
böylece
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyonun
ikinci
parametresi
stut function'ın
int
açılımı
türünden
değil mi
bu da ne demek
ben bu fonksiyonun
ikinci
parametresine
bir fonksiyon
adresi
gönderebileceğim
gibi
bir function
object
az önce
gördüğünüz
örneklerdeki
bütün varlıkları
gönderebilirim
hepsi
bu parametrik
yapıda
bir kolu
değil mi
yani bu
fonksiyonun
ikinci
parametresine
bir lambda
ifadesi de
geçebilirim
stut
bind'in
geri dönüş
değerini de
geçebilirim
sevgili
arkadaşlar
efendim
bir
doğrudan
callable
function
object
fonksiyon
adresi
stut bind
artık
int int
parametrik yapıya
sahip
herhangi bir
kolu
geçebilirim
yani
holdback
mekanizmasını
çok daha
genelleştirmiş
oluyoruz
kullanılan
tipik senaryolardan
biri bu
arkadaşlar
ya da
ikinci tipik
senaryo
callable
bir
konteynerda
tutmak
bakın
bir fonksiyonu
doğrudan
bir konteynerda
tutamazsınız
ama
stut function
nesnelerini
bir konteynerda
tutabilirsiniz
mesela
izleyin
using
örneği
dikkatli
izleyin
f type
eşittir
stut function
int
arkadaşlar
açılımı
ve şimdi
şöyle bir vektör
oluşturabilir miyim
vektörün
f type
açılımı
pvek
reserve
oraya bakmayın
şimdi ben bu fonksiyona
geri dönüş değeri
int
parametresi
int olan
imzaya sahip
herhangi bir
kolu bulu
bu vektöre
insert edebilirim
ister
bunu
pushback
fonksiyonuyla yapın
ister
and place
back
fonksiyonuyla
yapın
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
mesela
f
back
arkadaşlar
and place
back'e
constructora gönderecek
argümanları gönderiyorum
değil mi
dolayısıyla
bakınız
f
back
and place
ne kadar güzel
lambda
int x
return
x
çarpı x
olur mu
tabi ki
az önceki örneklerin
herhangi biri
ya da birden fazlası
int
u
int a
return
arkadaşlar
ya da
arabize isim vereyim
int q
int a
return
a çarpı
a
bakın
f
back
and place
cube
plus
a kaç
tarpı
puncture
ya da
struct
puncture
int
operatör fonksiyon
çağrı
int
a
return
2 çarpı
a çarpı
a
add back
and place back
puncture
arkadaşlar
üçününün de ortak özelliği
ben
em place back
fonksiyonuyla
vektörde tutulan
stut function
nesnelerinin
konstruktörüne
gönderecek
argümanları
gönderdim
ya da
yine
son örneğimiz
olsun
int
buzz
int a
int b
return
hadi buzz da olmasın
ismi
bari
sum square
return
a çarpı
a
artı
b çarpı
b
f
back
and place back
hocam böyle bir durumda fonksiyon adresi geçirmesi gereken yere iteratör geçebilir miyiz
tabii ki hayır
arkadaşlar ama
o iteratör konumunda
bir stut function nesnesi varsa
iteratör geçemezsiniz ama
iteratörü
dereferans edebilirsiniz
anlaşıldı mı
iteratörün de oradan
bununla bir ilgisi yok
şimdi bakın
bind
sum square
placeholders
underscore bir
şimdi ben bu vektörü dolaşsam
arkadaşlar
for
auto
ref
f
back
auto
y
eşittir
f
on
see out
while
döngünler durumda
vektörde tutulan kolumlardan
birini çağırmış oluyorum
bir ara vereceğim
müsaadenizle
evet
peki
saat
21.02
21.20'de devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
sorunan sorulardan biri
kürüşmazlığı
örnekte
stut function'ın
float
açılımı
yani aslında
arkadaşlar
sarmalayacağı fonksiyon
hangi parametrik yapıda olması gerekiyor
geri dönüş değerine float
parametresi float
fakat
stut function
nesnesine
yukarıda tanımlanan
full fonksiyonuyla
ilk değer veriyorum
initialize ediyorum
burada
ne olur sorusunun cevabı
şöyle demiştim
duruma göre değişir
çünkü dönüşüm yapılamayacak
gibiyse
sentaks hatası olacak
ama dönüşüm yapılabiliyorsa
veri kaybı olabilir
ya da olmayabilir
ama tipik olarak
derleyicimizden
bir
uyarı mesajı
alırız
arkadaşlar bakın
derleyicinin
verdiği
uyarı mesajı
tabi
template kodlarda
biraz fazla uzun oluyor
ama bakın
arkadaşlar
float türünden
int türüne
dönüşümde
veri kaybı
olabileceğine
yönelik
bir uyarı mesajı var
yani
kodun kendi
sentaks hatası
değil
ama kullanımda
burada
aslında
sonuçta
çağrılacak fonksiyon
full fonksiyonu
fakat
gönderilen argüman
float
int'e dönüştürülecek
ve veri kaybolacak
ondalık kısmı
kaybolacak
o zaman
12 değerini
göndermiş olacağız
ve fonksiyonumuzda
144 değerini
döndürmüş olacak
yani bunun
faydalı bir şekilde
veri kaybı olmadan
kullanılmasında
bir engel yok
ama veri kaybı
olması
kötü tabii
onu duruma göre
sentaks hatası da
olabilirdi
gönderilen
argüman
ilgili fonksiyonun
parametre değişkenine
dönüşemeyecek
durumdaysa
o zaman da
sentaks hatası
olurdu
peki
şimdi
değerli arkadaşlar
nereye geldik
bir de
üye fonksiyonlarla
kullanımı
yani bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonunu da
stut function'la
sarma diyebilirsiniz
herhangi bir şekilde
bir engel yok
ama bu durumda
fonksiyonun imzasına
yani template parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanına
dikkat etmeliyiz
çünkü bu durumda
fonksiyon türünün
birinci parametresi
ya
myclass
referans türü
ya da
myclass
eğer sınıfın ismi
myclass ise
myclass
pointer türü olacak
yani örneğin
class
myclass
sınıfının
üye fonksiyonları
olsun
public
arkadaşlar
int
bu
bu sefer
fonksiyonları
çağırmayayım
sadece
legalitesini
sorgulayalım
ya da isterseniz
gösterelim
çağrıldığını
gösteren bir yazı
yazdıralım
en azından
myclass'ın
bu
int
işte bu fonksiyon
çağrıldığında
bir değerini
döndürsün
bir fonksiyon
daha olsun
hatta bu da
konstüya fonksiyon
olsun
ve iki değerini
göndürsün
sub
function
bakın
int
arkadaşlar
parametresi
myclass
ref
hakip edebiliyor muyuz
int
myclass
ref
birinci fonksiyon
için
int parametresi
varmış
o zaman
myclass
ref
int
diyelim ki
f1
eşit
bir
myclass'ın
bu fonksiyonu
şimdi bu fonksiyonu
çağırırken
şöyle çağıracağım
değil mi
örneğin
bir myclass
nesnem var
myclass
m
ve
f
m
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
f değilmiş
f1'miş
ismi
böylece
bu fonksiyonla
yıldız
diz olarak
m nesnesi
geçecek
fonksiyonun
int parametresine
de
20 değeri
geçecek
const
f1'ı
fonksiyonu
için
şuraya
const
yazmanız
gerekecek
const
myclass
örneğin
myclass'ın
fool'su
değil
myclass'ın
barı
ama adres yaparsanız
soru var galiba
evet
adres yaparsanız
myclass
yıldız
bu durumda
fonksiyona da
f1 olsun yine
nesnenin adresini
geçeceksin
yine aynı şekilde
const myclass
yıldız
adres myclass
bar
bar fonksiyonu
const
yıldız
yine nesnenin
adresini
geçeceğim
arkadaşlar
son olarak
stot function'ı
nerelerde
kullandığımızı
bir kez daha
vurgulamak istiyorum
artık konuyu
değiştireceğim
bir
en tipik
kullanımı
generalized
callback
yani
bir fonksiyonun
parametresine
stot function
türünden
olması
arkadaşlar
bu arada
bir şeye
daha değineyim
yeni aklıma geldi
bakın şimdi
belirli bir
c++
standartına
kadar
auto return
type yoktu
dolayısıyla
bir fonksiyondan
bir closure
object döndürmek
için stot function'ı
kullanıyorduk
yani şimdi
bir fonksiyonumuz
olsun
şimdi şöyle
yazıyoruz
auto
bu
örneğin
return
index
lambda
x
int
return
a
çarpı
x
şimdi bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
bir closure
type
ama
bu c++14'de geldi
daha önce
şöyle yazıyorduk
arkadaşlar
major
stot function
kullanıyordu
yani stot function'ın
kullanım senaryolarından biri de
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş değeri olması
özellikle template'lerde
bu halen
kullanılabilir bir senaryo
ama auto işimizi
kolaylaştırıyor
ama auto
olmasaydı
stot function'ın
int
arkadaşlar
bu şekilde
bir geri dönüş
değeri
olabilirdi
sonuçta
lambda'nın
parametrik yapısıyla
stot function'ın
beklediği fonksiyon
yapısı
uyuşuyor
ama burada bir şeyde
dikkat edelim
arkadaşlar stot function
çok ucuz değil
yani stot function'ı
kullandığınız
yerlerde
bazı
fazladan
işlem maliyetlerini
göze
almalısınız
artı
bir de
bellek alanı
hesaba bakınız
using
f-type
eşittir
stot function'un
int
specialization
cout
size of
f-type
bakın 40 byte
yani
bir function pointer
olsaydı
derleyicinize bağlı
şekilde
4 byte
8 byte
olacaktı
ama stot function
nesnesi
benim derleyicimde
bütün derleyicilerde
aynı olmak zorunda
değil
40 byte
dolayısıyla
basit bir function pointer'a göre
çok daha fazla
bellek alanına
ihtiyaç duyuyor
ve
belirli
overhead'i var
yani stot function'u
kullandığınız zaman
bedava
değil
bir function pointer'a göre
daha yüksek maliyette
o yüzden
kullanılmasının
gerekli
zorunlu olmadığı
senaryolarda
kullanımından
kaçınmakta
fayda var
ama yine de
son notumuza
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar
bir
fonksiyon parametresi
böylece
callback yapısını
daha da
genelleştirmiş oluyoruz
bazen
fonksiyon geri dönüş
diğeri türü
böylece
fonksiyon
herhangi türden
bir
callable
döndürebiliyor
herhangi türden
derken
belirli parametrik
yapıya sahip
fonksiyon sağlayan
herhangi bir
callable
döndürebiliyor
sınıfların
bu da
yaygın
misine
senaryo
statik
ya da
daha çok
non-static
veri elemanlarının
bir
ya da
birden fazla
veri elemanının
data
member'ın
stot
function
türünleri
olması
ve
sub-function
nesnelerini
bir
konteynerda
tutmak
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu
4.
senaryo
özellikle
önemli
neden
bakın
c
geçmişi
olan
arkadaşlar
için
konuşuyorum
c'de de
çok
kullanıyoruz
değil mi
function
pointer
array
şimdi
örneğin
c'de
tabi aynı
durum
c++'da
da
geçerli
şöyle bir
function
pointer
type
olsaydı
using
fptr
eşittir
int
yıldız
ve ben
şimdi
elemanları
fptr
bunun c kodu
olduğunu düşündüm
using
dışında
ama tamamen
c kodu
yapmak
istersem
int
yıldız
fptr
başına
type
def
koyacağım
şimdi
elemanları
fptr
türünden
olan
bir dizi
oluşturup
bu dizinin
elemanlarının
fonksiyon adresleri
olmasını sağlayabilirim
ve böylece bu diziyi
farklı farklı
amaçlar için
kullanabilirim
mesela bu
bu dizi
İngilizce karşılığıyla
bir
jump table
olabilir
bir
arkadaşlar
yine
look up table
olarak kullanabilirim
yani
indeksle
bir fonksiyonun
adresine
erişip
o adresteki fonksiyonu
çağırabilirim
bazen
kümülatif bazı
işlemleri yapmak için
örneğin
bir
algoritmanın
basamakları
olabilir
yani ben
bir döngüsler yapı
içinde
böyle bir dizide
adreslere tutulan
fonksiyonları
belirli bir sırayla
çağırabilirim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
işte
C'de böyle bir
fonksiyon
nesneleri
hangi amaçla
ya da amaçlarla
hangi senaryolarda
kullanabilirseniz
bir
konteyner
stot
fonksiyon
nesneleri
tutuyorsa
onu da aynı
amaçlarla
kullanabilirsiniz
ama daha
genelleştirmiş
oluyorsunuz
değil mi
işte az önceki
örneği
hatırlayın
vektörün
bu sefer
türeş ismi
kullanmayacağım
vektörün
function'ın
int
specialization'ı
efrek
şimdi bu
böyle bir
konteyner'a
ben
çeşitli
kolobulları
koyup
artık
indekse
erişim mi
isterim
kümülatif olarak
bunların hepsinin
sırayla
çağrılmasını
mı isterim
ya da
arkadaşlar
bir
yine
indekste
erişip
belirli bir
lojik yapıyla
bir kolobulların
çağrılmasını
mı isterim
ama diğerinden
farkı ne
artık burada
tutulanlar
herhangi bir
aynı parametrik
yapıda
fonksiyon veren
herhangi bir
kolobull
olabilir
bu da tabi
çok daha büyük
esneklik
ve genellik
sağlıyor
peki
şimdi konuyu
değiştiriyoruz
STL'de
biraz da
eksiğimiz var
o eksikleri
hemen kapatacağız
arkadaşlar
bu arada
stud function
ile ilgili
bir öğeden
daha bahsedeceğim
arkadaşlar
c++
17 ile
eklenen
bir
stud invoke
şimdi stud invoke
özellikle
jenerik kodlarda
kullanılmaya
aday
biliyorsunuz
invoke
terimi
çağırmak
anlamında
da kullanılıyor
yani
to
call a function
demekle
to call a function
ingilizcede
to
invoke a function
demek
aynı anlamda
stud invoke'da
adı üstünde
arkadaşlar
genel bir
fonksiyon
çağırıcısı
ama stud invoke'un
kendisi
bakınız
invoke
yapısını bir
görmenizi
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
invoke'un
kendisi
bir
fonksiyon
şablonu
ama
öyle bir
fonksiyon
şablonu ki
siz bu
fonksiyon
şablonunun
birinci
parametresine
bir
callable
verip
diğer
parametrelerine
de
o
callable
ile
çağrılacak
o
callable'ın
çağrılmasına
kullanılacak
argümanları
geçiyorsunuz
stud invoke
sizin için
o callable'ı
o argümanlarla
çağırıyor
arkadaşlar
yani örneğin
şimdi basit
kullanımından
başlayalım
farklı farklı
callable'lar
oluşturalım
önce
class
functor
ya da
struct functor
diyelim ki
bunun bir
fonksiyonu
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonu
olsun
public
int
operatör
fonksiyon
çağrı
int
x
fonksiyonu
olsun
ve
return
x
çarpı
on
bu
bu bir
bekleyin
biraz
bir
harbi
fonksiyonumuz
olsun
arkadaşlar
hatta fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
yazdırolim
c
out
u
alt
argümanları yazdırmıyorum
artık
efendim
return
a çarpı
a
artı
b
çarpı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
e şimdi bakalım
hatta hatta
bir sınıfın
üye fonksiyonu
olsun
class
my class
public
void
for
int
see out
my class
for
int
x
y
seferde
aldıralım
argümanları
x
eşit
y
şimdi
bakınız
stud
invoke
birinci parametresi her zaman
callable
örneğin
fool
diğer parametrelerine
arkadaşlar
argümanları geçiyorum
geri dönüşlerini
bir değişkende
saklayayım
hatta val değişkeninin
değerini yazdırayım
derleyip çalıştırıyorum
bakın fonksiyonun gerçekten çağrıldığını görüyorsunuz
ama sadece böyle bir fonksiyonun çağrılmasını sağlamıyor
mesela şu anda bir de
functor
kolumuna bakın
geçe nesne
arkadaşlar
ek parametreliymiş
bu seferde bu fonksiyon çağrılacak
yani
yok ki invoke
bana bir callable
ve o callable'ın
çağrılmasına gerekli
argümanları gönder
ben sana
o callable'ı
senin için
çağırayım
argümanları da
ona pas edeyim
jenerik kodlarda kullanımı
daha önemli
ama
üye fonksiyonlarla da
çağırabiliyorsunuz
özellikle bakınız
bu arada
fonksiyon adresi de
olabilirdi
şimdi
myclass'ın
foo üye fonksiyonuna bakın
elimde bir
myclass nesnesi var
myclass
me
arkadaşlar
ve
invoke fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
invoke fonksiyonuna
neyi çağırtacağım
myclass'ın
foo fonksiyonunu
çağırtacağım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yapabilir miyim bunu
invoke
callable olarak
myclass'ın
foo fonksiyonunun
adresi
me
on
yirmi
non-static
üye fonksiyonu olduğuna
dikkat edin
ve
çağırıyorum
fakat asıl güzel tarafı
member
function pointer
kullanımını
kolaylaştırıyor
şimdi benim bir tane
fonksiyonum olsaydı
fonksiyon pointer'ım
olsaydı
myclass'ın
ya da şöyle yazayım
auto
f
eşittir
adres
myclass
foo
şimdi şöyle çağırmam
gerekirdi
değil mi
m
nokta yıldız
f
on
yirmi
geçen derslerden birinde
görmüştük
üye fonksiyon pointer'ı ile
f sınıfın üye fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
ama
sentaks biraz zorlayıcı
nokta yıldız
operatörünü
kullanıyorum
öncelik yüzünden
öncelik
parantezi
içine alıyorum
hatta hatta
eğer fonksiyonun
neslinin
adresi elimde ise
myclass
yıldız
mp
geçen dersimizin konusuydu
eşittir
adres m
şimdi şöyle çağıracağım
m
ok yıldız
p
efendim
kırk
altmış
takip edebiliyor muyuz
m
dedim özür dilerim
mp
idi
oyıntı
mp
ok yıldız
ve
kırk
altmış
fonksiyonun
gerçekten
çağrıldığını
göreceksiniz
ama
böyle yazmaya
göre
bakın şöyle yazmak
çok daha kolay
izleyin
studi invok
template kodu olduğu için
çözümlemesini
kendisi yapacak
arkadaşlar
kolabal olarak
adres
myclass
fo
ya da
function pointer ile
çağıracak
gözleri
örneğin
function pointer
olan
f
m
ya da
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
f yerine
m yerine
özür dilerim
neyi kullanabilirim
mp
yani
çözümlemesini
kendisi yapıyor
ben
function pointer'ı
member function pointer'ı
invoke'un
birinci parametresine
argüman olarak
geçiyorum
arkadaşlar
diğer parametrelerine
sınıf nesnesini
sınıf nesnesi
adresini
ve fonksiyona
gönderilecek
argümanları
geçiyorum
takip edebildik mi
evet
hatta
data member pointer'ı
da
kullanabilirim
yani
orada da
yine
işimi görür
ama onlar
şimdilik bizim için
detay
sadece
invoke isimli
bir fonksiyon çağrıcısının
varlığından
şimdilik haberdar
olmanız yeterli
ne yapıyormuşuz
birinci parametresine
callable'ı
diğer parametrelerine
o callable'a
gönderecek
argümanları
geçiyoruz
arka planda
perfect forwarding
mekanizması
kullanılıyor
ve fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri de
bizim detaylı
görmediğimiz ama
ilerisi
last class
kursunda
detaylı anlattım
perfect returning
mekanizmasıyla
yine
elde ediliyor
o zaman
hemen bir sonraki
konumuza
geçiyoruz
arkadaşlar
bazı
STL
algoritmaları
evet
şimdiye kadar
görmediğimiz
birkaç
algoritmaya
daha değineceğim
evet
STL
algoritmaları
serimize
biraz daha
ekleme yapalım
arkadaşlar
yine
üretimde
çok sık
kullanmaya
aday
bazı
algoritmalardan
bahsedeceğim
bunlardan
bir tanesi
generate
algoritması
aslında
geçen
derste
reference
wrapper
sınıfını
anlatırken
sınıf şablonunu
bir örnekte
de kendisini
kullanmıştım
generate
algoritması
bir
inçteki
öğeleri
bir
generator'ın
ürettiği
geri dönüş
değeriyle
set ediyor
yani
aslında
çok basit
bir algoritma
algoritma
şöyle
yani
algoritmanın
kodunu
biz yazsaydık
birinci
parametresi
iteratörün
türü
en az
forward
iteratör
istiyor
o yüzden
for it
ismini
verdim
ikinci
template
parametresi
generator'ün
türü
hard name
generator
diyelim
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri yok
ismi
küçük
harfi
ama
benimki
orijinaliyle
çakışmasın
büyük harfi
olsun
generate
birinci
ve ikinci
parametresi
range
yani
for it
back
and
üçüncü
parametresi
generator
burada
geçen derse
yaptığım
uyarıya
dikkat
fonksiyonun
parametresi
referans
değil
dolayısıyla
büyük
generator
nesneleri
varsa
onların
kopyalanma
maliyetini
düşünün
ve
reference
wrapper'la
geçmeye
çalışın
arkadaşlar
peki
kod
nasıl
ya işte
back
end'e
eşit
olmadığı
sürece
döngünler
durumda
back'i
arttırıyor
ve
yıldız
bg
generator'ımızın
geri dönüş
değerine
atıyor
böylece
üçüncü
parametreye
geçtiğimiz
colable'ın
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeriyle
biz
oranj'deki
öğelerin
hepsini
ne yapmış
oluyoruz
set etmiş
birkaç örnek
yapalım
bu kalsın
isterseniz
orijinaline
çağıracağım
mesela
bakın
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
100 tane
v olsun
generate
argotin
başlık
listesinde
tabi ki
ibek
begin
ya da
ibek
end
şimdi
colable olarak
bir fonksiyon
verebilirsiniz
mesela bakın
en basit örnek
round
jstd
li
tabi çok kötü bir fikir
round'a kullanmak
ama sonuçta
ne yapacak
buradaki
öğeleri
round'ın
geri dönüş
değeriyle
dolduracak
burada
generator olarak
standart
c fonksiyonu
round'a kullandım
ama
tabi ki
bir
lambda
ifadesi de
olabilirdi
örneğin
arkadaşlar
parametresi
olmayacak
dolayısıyla
bunu hiç
yazmasam
da olur
return
round
mod
bu sefer de
generator olarak
closure
type'ı
kullanmış
oldum
c
print
arkadaşlar
neydi
ismi
ibek
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
çok pratik
bir kod
göstereceğim
idiomatik bir yapı
hadi bakalım
soru
bu vektörü
gibi
değerlerle
doldurun
yani
ilk öğesi
2 olacak
ikinci öğesi
4 olacak
üçüncü öğesi
6 olacak
evet
aklınıza bir fikir
geliyor ama
yani bunu
en pratik
şekilde
nasıl yaparsınız
arkadaşlar
lambda
ifadelerinde
bir şeyi
hatırlıyor musunuz
bir
oraya bir
gönderme
yapalım
şimdi bu
lambda
intro
diyor
sırr
doğru mu
evet
şu
sentaksı
hatırlıyor
musunuz
arkadaşlar
x eşittir
diyelim ki
sıfır
herkes
hatırlıyor mu
bunu
bu ne
demek
sınıfta
bir veri
elemanı
aslında
ona
x ismini
verdim
derleyicinin
yazdığı
sınıfta
derleyici
sınıfa
bir
non-static
data
member
koyacak
onu
bu değerle
initialize
edecek
böylece
ben
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör
fonksiyonunda
sınıfın
veri elemanı
olan
x'i
kullanabileceğim
mesela şöyle
yazsaydım
int a
arkadaşlar
efendim
return
x eşittir
5 olsun
return
x
çarpı
buna
lambda
init
capture
deniyordu
hatırladınız mı
sentaksa
lambda
init
capture
bakın şimdi
buraya geldim
lambda
init
capture
kullanıyorum
x
eşittir
takip edebildik mi
ama
lambda'ya bakın
arkadaşlar
mutable
neden mutable
yaptım
çünkü sınıfın
veri elemanını
değiştireceğim
bakın mutable'a
çok iyi bir örnek
daha
eğer bu mutable
olmasaydı
mutable
spesifier'ını
kullanmasaydım
şöyle yazsaydım
arkadaşlar
return
x artı
eşit
neden
sentaksa
taslı olur
yiğit
olsan
çünkü
hatırlayın
lambda ifadelerini
bravo
constüe fonksiyon
burada sınıfın
constüe fonksiyonu
sınıfın
veri elemanını
değiştiriyor
ama ben
mutable
dersem
derleyicinin yazdığı
yiğit fonksiyon
constüe fonksiyonu
olmaktan çıkıyor
non-constüe fonksiyonu
oluyor
olduğu için
arkadaşlar
nesnenin değerini
değiştirebiliyorum
ama şimdi
espriye bakın
bu sınıfın
veri elemanı
değil mi
evet
o zaman
ben bunu
generate algoritmasına
argüman olarak
geçtiğimde
bu fonksiyon
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
sınıfın
veri elemanı
2 artacak
sonra
bir daha
2 artacak
çünkü
aynı sınıf
nesnesini
kullanıyorum
değil mi
burayı anladık mı
yani
generate algoritmasına
burada
çağrı yapan
kod
sonuçta
aynı
kolubulu
kullanıyor
sınıfın
veri elemanındaki
arkadaşlar
değeri
yeni değeri
kullanmış oluyor
bu arada
bir not daha
belki
unutmuş olabilecek
arkadaşlarım olabilir
arkadaşlar
bu
bir atama
operatörü
atama operatörünün
ürettiği değer
zaten
nesneye atanan
değerdir
değil mi
dolayısıyla
bu fonksiyon
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
x'in
değeri
2 artacak
ama bu
ifadenin
değeri
de
böylece
ilk öğe
2 olacak
ben
x'e
eksi 2 değerini
verseydim
0 değeriyle
başlardı
şimdi
c
print
hadi
daha
kısa olsun
10 tane
öğe ile
dolduralım
gördünüz mü
şık değil mi
ya da
şuna ne dersiniz
daha önce
kullandık bunu
vektörün
string açılımı
svec
bakın
generate
svec
arkadaşlar
svec begin
svec end
ve
random name
aslında bir
string döndüren
fonksiyon
generator
olarak bu
fonksiyon
kullanıldı
yani
yukarıdaki döngüye
bakın
zaten duruyormuş
döngünler
turunda
aslında
random name
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
tabi derleyicinin
yazdığı fonksiyonun
üçüncü parametresi
bu durumda
function pointer
olacak
c
print
svec
ama burada
şüphesiz
ne de
kullanabilirdim
yine
lambda ifadesi
kullanabilirdim
hatta bazı örnekleri
böyle yazdım
hatırlıyor musunuz
bakın
generator olarak
lambda ifadesi
ama bu kez
random name
arkadaşlar
artı
bir boşluk
random
surname
önce bu fonksiyon
her çağrıldığında
rastgele bir isim
ve soy isimler
oluşan
bir
string
döndürecek
değil mi
küve parantezi
parantez
tabi yan yana
yazdırmayalım
bir
hepsini
alt satıra
yazdıralım
evet
vektören
string açılımı
tabi
return
anahtar sözcüğü
unutulmuş
şimdi
tamam
generate'in
ne iş yaptığını
anlatınız mı
ama buna yakın
bir fonksiyon
daha var
bu fonksiyonun
ismi de
generate n
aslında
neredeyse
aynı işi yapıyor
fakat
biraz daha
farklı yapıda
önce
bu sefer de
generate n'in
kodunu
bir yazalım
burayı siliyorum
hepsini
sileyelim
bakın
generate n'de
şöyle bir
algoritma
pamplet
bu sefer
output iteratörü
istiyor
output iter
arkadaşlar
bunun ikinci
parametresi
template parametresi
daha var
adet türünün de
bir template
parametresi
yapmışlar
iyi bir fikir mi
yani bunu doğrudan
örneğin size t
yapılabilirdi ama
çok daha esnek
olsun diye
tane adet türünün
ne olduğunu da
yine bir
template
type parametresi
yapmışlar
type name
generator
sefer gen
ismini vereyim
fonksiyon
şablonu
ismi
generate
ama sefer
geri dönüş
değeri
alt iter
ismi
generate
n
tabii küçük
harf
alt iter
back
size türünden
diyelim ki
cn t
gen türünden
g
ne yapıyor
size türünden
değişken
diyelim ki
i
eşit
sıfır
i
i küçüktür
cn t
yani
kesin
dönen
döngü
artı
arkadaşlar
back
döngünün
gövdesinde
de
inanç
yıldız
back
eşittir
y
sadece
parametrik
yapısı
farklı
ve geri dönüş
değeri
bütün yazma
algoritmalarında
olduğu gibi
son yazdığı
konumdan
sonraki
konum
ama sefer
örneği şöyle
kullanabilirim
değil mi
daha farklı
kullanım
olanağı
sunuyor
mesela
back
görün
int
açılımı
ibek
generate
n
birinci
parametresi
arkadaşlar
ibek'in
begin'i
kaç tane
ö
10 tane
ya da
5 tane
tamamını
doldurmak
zorunda
diyelim
işte az önceki
örnekte olduğu
gibi
stut
round
ya da
deployable
lambda
ifadesi
stut
round
return
mod
ama
tabi burada
şöyle bir
olanak da var
doğrudan
stream'e de
verebilirim
öyle değil mi
çünkü
benden
output
iteratörü
istiyor
mesela
bakınız
vektörün
string
açılımı
ya da
şöyle
onu da
karıştırmayalım
bakın bakın
güzel bir şey
yapalım
şimdi
generate'ini
çağıralım
arkadaşlar
birinci parametresine
o stream
iteratörün
string açılımı
see out
hatırlıyorsunuz
o stream iteratör
sınıfına
boşluk
ikinci parametresine
üçüncü parametresine
random
name'i
gönderip
böylece
random
name'in
20 kez
çağıracak
geri dönüş
değerinde
o stream
iteratörün
string açılımını
kullandığım için
ve birinci parametresine
o stream
nesnesi olarak
see out'u
geçtiğim için
o stream'e
insert edecek
yani bu da ne demek
20 tane ismi
tek bir fonksiyon
çağrısıyla
böyle
yazdırmış
olacağım
ya da
az önceki örnek
benzeri
lambda
return
random name
artı
random
surname
burada da
separatör stringi olarak
new line'i
kullanalım
bu sefer de
20 tane
isim ve
soy isim
yazdırmış olacak
gördük mü
evet
arkadaşlar
bir başka
algoritma
fill n
bu da
çok basit
bir algoritma
belirli bir rençteki
öğeleri
belirli bir değere
atıyor
olabilecek en basit
ama
kullanılmaya da
aday
üretimde
etkili bir algoritma
zaten
algoritmalar
kompleks kodlar
değil ki
önemli olan
isimlendirilmiş
fonksiyon haline getirip
ham döngülerden
kaçınmak
peki
fill n
algoritması
nasıl
o da şöyle
yine
önce
algoritmayı
kodlayalım
template type name t
type name t
yerine
yine
output iter
out iter
birinci template
parametresi
yazılacak
rengin
iteratörü
türü
ikinci
template
parametresi
yine
tane adet
türü
üçüncü
template
parametresi
atanacak
değerin
türü
type name
out iter
iteratör
türü
kontrol edelim
tane adet
türü
ve
atanacak
değerin
türü
yine
geri dönüş
değeri
bir öncekinde
geri dönüş
değerini yazmayı
unuttum
şimdi fark ettim
neyse
out iter
arkadaşlar
fill n
out iter
back
size
ya da
cnt
ve
arkadaşlar
dönüştür
const
e
rep
var
ne yapıyor
yine
or
size
i
eşittir
cnt
ve
sıfır
i küçük
cnt
yani
count
as
dönen bir
döngü
arkadaşlar
artı
i
döngünün
gövdesinde
yıldız
back
artı
eşittir
val
öylece
aralıktaki
bütün
üveleri
val
değeriyle
doldurmuş oluyor
tabi
bir önceki
algoritmada
return yazmayı
unuttum
ama şimdi
yazalım
bari
return
back
en son
yazdığı
konumdan
sonraki
konumu
döndürüyor
mesela
yine bir
basit örnek
bu sefer
elimizde
bir
list
konteynerı
olsun
listin
arkadaşlar
string açılımı
my list
20 tane
ö olsun
ve
fill
end
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
global
algoritmayı
algoritmanın
birinci
parametresine
my list
in
beginli
ikinci
parametresine
değerini
özellikle
10 geçiyorum
üçüncü
parametresine
de
örneğin
necati
değerini
geçeyim
geri dönüş
değerini
bir
iteratörde
zaptayım
böylece
begin
iter
aralığını
necati
yazısıyla
doldurmuş
oldum
arkadaşlar
range
print
komisyonumu
çağırayım
jprint
my list
begin
aslında
listinin
size
my list
begin
ve
iter
hatta
end
ismini
vereyim
bu da
plan
fonksiyonu
devam edelim
üçüncü
algoritmamız
oldu
generate
n
ve
fill
n
fonksiyonları
arkadaşlar
şimdi
ayrı bir
algoritma
grubuna
geçeceğim
daha önce
konuşmadığımız
bir algoritma
grubu
ya da
kısmen
konuştuk
bu gruba
sorted
range
algorithms
deniyor
aslında biz
bu gruptan
lower bound
upper bound
ve equal range
fonksiyonlarını
gördük
bazı
algoritmalar
şimdi
isimlerini
telaffuz ettiğimiz
sıralanmış
range'ler
üstünde
işlem
yapıyorlar
o yüzden
bu algoritmaların
oluşturduğu
gruba
sorted range
algorithms
deniyor
üç
tanesini
az önce
söyledim
isimlerini
saydım
gördük
ama
bunların dışında
arkadaşlar
başka
sorted range
algoritmaları
da var
mesela
önce
basitlerinden
başlayalım
set
union
intersection
set
difference
ve set
symmetric
difference
alan elemanlar
birleşim
a
b
iki
kümedeki
elemanlarının
birleşimi
efendim
fark
a'nın
b'den
farkı
a'da olan
b'de
olmayanlar
simetrik
farkı
a
simetrik
fark
b
a'da olan
b'de
olmayanlarla
b'de olan
a'da olmayanların
birleşim kümesi
şimdi bu algoritmalar
nasıl çalışıyor
öncelikle
bunların
önce en basitinden
başlayalım
bakın
set
ne demiştik
intersection
arkadaşlar
hepsinin parametrik
yapısı
aynı
ama dikkatli bir şekilde
dinlemeniz
gerekiyor
biraz kafanız
karışabilir
şuradan
yine
pointer'ımı
açayım
evet
bakın şimdi
ne yapıyor
set
intersection
üç tane
template
parametresi var
parametresi
birinci ve ikinci template
arkadaşlar
iki tane
range'in
başlangıcını
alacak
ama tabi bu range'ler
iki tane range'in
iteratörleri olduğu için
farklı türler
yani
range'ler
kesişimini
birleşimini
farkını alacağım
range'ler
aynı
konteynere
ilişkin olmak
zorunda değil
biri
input olarak
kullanılacak
bir range'in
iteratörü
diğeri
input olarak
kullanılacak
diğer range'in
iteratörü
bir de yazma
range'imiz var
yani
kesişimi
birleşimi
farkı
yazacağımız
onun
template
parametresi de
ayrı
fonksiyon
parametrelerine
gelince
son derece
basit
ilk iki
parametre
birinci
input range'e
ilişkin
üçüncü
dördüncü
parametre
ikinci
input range'in
begin'i
end'i
aynı sayıda
öve olması
gerekmiyor
ve fonksiyonun
beşinci
parametresi
yazma
range'inin
başlangı
literatörü
o konumdan
itibaren
yazacak
ama bir örnek
tabi
bütün yazma
algoritmalarında
olduğu gibi
geri dönüş
değeri
en son
yazılan
konumdan
sonraki
konum
arkadaşlar
yalnız
dikkat
bu
sorted range
algoritmaları
sorted
olmayan
bir range'le
çağırırsanız
kesinlikle
undefined
diyebilir
dolayısıyla
bu algoritmaları
çağırdığınız zaman
range'lerin
sorted
olması ve
aynı kritere
bağlı olarak
sorted
olması
gerekiyor
bütün bu
algoritmaların
tahmin edebildiğiniz
gibi
o sıralama
kriterini
alan
bir
ilave
overload'u
var
birinci
overload'u
kullanırsanız
studless'le
sıralamanın
yapıldığını
kabul edecek
ama
diğer overload
sıralamada
kullanılan
komparatörü
isteyecek
hadi bir örnek
verelim
bakın
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
ya da
tamam
listin
int açılımı
ilist
vektörün
int açılımı
destvek
şimdi ne yapacağım
bu iki konteynere
doldurup
sıralama
sıralama işlemi
yapacağım
ve sonra
size göstermek
için
arkadaşlar
set intersection
set union
set difference
set symmetric difference
fonksiyonlarını
tek tek çağıracağım
ama
işimi kolaylaştırmak
için
bir tane
arkadaşlar
generator
oluşturayım
izleyin
ya da
zaten
generator'ım
hazır
benim
neutrity
kütüphanemde
var
o zaman
başlayalım
şu benim
random field
fonksiyonum
ivek
arkadaşlar
20 tane
ö
ve
irant
random field
i list
10 tane
ö
ya da
15 tane
ö
aynı değerlerle
şimdi her ikisini de
sıralıyorum
sort
ivek
begil
and
aynı sıralama
kriteriyle
sıralanmış
olması gerekiyor
ama
listenin kendi
sort
fonksiyonu var
ilist
in
sortu
şimdi her ikisini de
yazdırayım
jprint
ivek
ilist
buraya kadar
aslında da
test ortamını
oluşturduk
elimizde iki tane
sıralı
range var
ve aynı sıralama
kriterine göre
sıralanmış
şimdi bakın
bunların
kesişim
kümesini
alsaydım
ikisinde de
iki tane
8 var
8 gelecek
bir tane
11 gelecek
kesişimin ne
olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
26'dan
bir tane
gelecek
şimdi
bunu
fonksiyonumuzu
çağıralım
set
intersection
birinci range
ivek
begin
end
üçüncü
dördüncü
parametre
ikinci input
range
ilist
begin
end
on parametre
output
range
ama dikkat
destvek
boş olduğu için
back inserter
destvek
tabi boş olmak zorunda değil
ya da back inserter
kullanmak zorunda değilim
ama back inserter'ı da
bir hatırlatmış olalım
bakın
şimdi
neyi yazdırıyorum
destvek
c print
ölçe
kesişimi
gayet güzel
görmüş olacağız
bakın
bir
burada
4 var
burada 4 var
sonra 9
ikisinde de ortak
aralığı biraz daraltayım
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi ikisinde de
iki tane sıfır olduğu için
iki tane sıfır geldi
ama bunda iki tane iki
bunda bir tane iki
bir tane iki geldi
ve
denize
ama ki
arkadaşlar çok işe yarıyor
bakın belki
şimdiye kadar
üretimde hiç kullanmamış
olabilirsiniz
ama kullanacağı yer çok fazla
şimdi
set intersection
yerine
set union'ı
çağıralım
bu sefer
set union
birleşim kümesi
ikisinin birleşimi
izleyin
arkadaşlar
sıfır buradan geldi
iki tane bir
buradan geldi
dört
altı
buradan geldi
söylemeye gerek yok
iki kümenin
birleşimi
üçüncüsü
anlamadığımız bir yer varsa
tekrar etmemi isteyin
set difference
birinci de olan
ikinci de olmayan
evet bakın
sıfır burada var
aşağıda yok
iki
arkadaşlar
bir tanesi
burada var
burada yok
üç
yukarıda var
aşağıda yok
iki tane
dört için
aynı şey
geçerli
üç tane
yedi için
aynı şey
geçerli
ama bakın
on beş
on altı
on sekiz
yazılmadı
üç tane
yirmi üç
yazıldı
yirmi dört
arkadaşlar
burada iki tane var
burada bir tane var
yazıldı
yirmi beş
ikisinde de
burada var
burada da var
yazılmadı
yirmi altı
yazıldı
ve yirmi dokuz
eğer
set difference'ı
bu şekilde
değil de
şöyle çağırsaydım
bunu yorum
satırını
alayım
sırayı
değiştirseydim
ilist begin
ilist end
arkadaşlar
ivek begin
ivek end
burada da
listede olan
fakat vektörde olmayanlar
olacaktı
evet bakın
iki iki
yedi yedi
burada yok
sekiz iki tane
birini yazdı
ama
simetrik
difference
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
biraz simetrik
difference'ı
görebilmek
için
aralığı
biraz daha
açayım
et simetrik
difference
evet
birinci de olan
ikinci de
olmayanlar
ikinci de olan
birinci de
olmayanların
birleşim
kümesi
sıfır
üsttekinde var
alttakinde yok
iki
üsttekinde var
alttakinde yok
arkadaşlar
üç
alttakinde var
üsttekinde yok
anlaşıldı değil mi
o zaman devam
sadece bunlar değil
bunlar set algoritmaları
sıralı rençler üstünde
bütün bu algoritmaların
sadece bir tanesini de
gösterelim
parametrik yapısına
bakarsanız
arkadaşlar
diğer bir
overloadun
lütfen bakın
diğer bir
overloadun
sizden
bir predikat
istediğini
göreceksiniz
bu ne demek
hemen isterseniz
bir tanesine
bunu örnek
olarak verelim
eğer
bu
container
rençler
farklı
sıralama
kriteriyle
sıralanmış
olsaydı
yani yine
ikisi aynı
ama sıralama
kriteriyle
isteyelim
mesela vektörü
sort ederken
büyükten küçüğe
sıralamak için
greater
funktörünü
kullanayım
listeyi
sıralarken
yine büyükten küçüğe
doğru sıralamak
için
yine orada da
greater
funktörünü
function objectini
kullanayım
standart
function object
ikisini
yazdırıyorum
ama set
difference'a bu sefer
ya da
set
intersection'a
eğer böyle
çağırsaydım
tanımsız
davranış
olacaktı
ama
ne geçeceğim
diğer
overload'ın
son parametresine
yine
karşılaştırma
kriterini
geçeceğim
greater
bu sefer
doğru
çalışacak
izleyin
arkadaşlar
sadece
50 ve
ortakmış
ikisinin sayısını da
20 yapalım
ya da
evet
20 yapalım
büyükten küçüğe sıralı
tabii ki
hedef vektörü de
büyükten küçüğe sıralı
ve
ortak
anlaşıldı mı
evet
arkadaşlar
ilginç bir algoritma
search algoritması
bu da
sort of change
ama search gerçekten
çok ilginç bir algoritma
doğru yerde
kullanırsanız
çok işe yarıyor
search
bakın bir search var
bir search
an var
şimdi
search'e bakın
evet
arkadaşlar
bu değil
tamam
şimdi bakın
fonksiyonun
fonksiyon şablonunun
yavaş yavaş gidelim
isimlendirmeyi
biraz kötü yapmışlar
üç tane
template parametresi var
arkadaşlar
tabii
bir tanesi
yine her zaman
olduğu gibi
lese oluyor
yaptığı iş şu
birinci ve ikinci
template parametreleri
sıralı birinci
range
onun içinde
arama yapacağız
üçüncü ve dördüncü
parametreleri
sıralı ikinci
range
birinci range
içinde
ikinci range
arayacağız
ve
ilk overload
yine
less
ikinci overload
karşılaştırma kriterini
istiyor
bu ne demek
aslında az önceki
örnetteki
vektörü ve listeyi
kullanayım
ve
bakın
yine
bir vektör
bir de
liste var
hatta
size daha iyi
gösterebilmek için
sadece
vektör olsun
çünkü
search'ü biraz
anlamak
zor olabiliyor
çünkü
search deyince
arkadaşlar
aslında
str'deki
find
akla geliyor
ama bunun
find ile alakası yok
bakın bakın
bu
sort-to-range
algoritma
isimlendirme kötü
sadece
yani bu
fonksiyonun
isminin
search olması
bence
hiç fonksiyonun
yapısına
uygun değil
dolduralım
random fill
ibek
ayrent
sort edelim
sort
ibek begin
ibek end
ve
bu kadar
jprint
kafanız karışacak başta
o yüzden
dikkatli izlemelisiniz
ve anlamadığınız yerde
soru sormalısınız
bakın şimdi
bu sıralı bir range
vektörde olabilirdi
sette olabilirdi
önemli olan
belirli bir sıralama
kriterine göre
sıralanmış olması
ben size
dört tane
sayı versem
mesela
burada
küçükten büyüğe
şekilde bu
değerler var mı
diye sorsam
ve 95
var değil mi
işte böyle bir
arama yapıyor
yani
birinci range'in
içinde
sıralı olarak
ikinci range
var mı
anladınız mı
arkadaşlar
evet bakın
şimdi
search'ü
çağıralım
arkadaşlar
evet
birinci
parametresine
hatta
şöyle yapalım
size daha
kolay gösterebilmek
için
şimdi daha da
boş olacak
sıralı olarak
yok
üç tane olsun
sıralı olarak
üç sayı girin
z
in
x
y
ve z
şimdi bunu
range haline getirmek için
bir initializer list
oluşturayım
initializer listin
arkadaşlar ya da şöyle
auto
list
eşittir
x
y
z
bölce list
initializer listin
int açılımı oldu
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
tabi ki
initializer listin de
begin ve end
fonksiyonları var
ve şimdi
arkadaşlar
auto
x
eşittir
search
ewek
begin
end
list
begin
end
x'in türü ne
bakan
arkadaşlar
iteratör
yani vektörün
int açılımının
iteratörü
if
x
eşit
değilse
ewek
end
özür dilerim
kaka yanlış
oldu
x
ismini
ilk kere
kullanmıştınız
evet
auto
iter
teşekkür
ederim
auto
iter
if
eşit
değilse
iwek'in
endi
siyahat
found
yıldız
iter
as
not found
göstereceğim
bakın
mesela
not found
şimdi
bakın
arkadaşlar
found
gördünüz mü
yani bir incinin içinde
bir ince arıyor
ama buna benzer bir fonksiyon daha var
o da benim dediğim gibi çalışacak
izleyin
var değil mi
bakın
found
bu
başladığı konumu buldu
bir de
searchen isimli bir fonksiyon var
ikisi
birbiriyle
benzer
ama farklı işler yapıyor
sıralı olarak
3 sayı girin
bulursak
bulunduğu konumu dönüyor
ama
buna benzer bir de
search
n fonksiyonu var
bunu da bir dahaki
derste
görelim
evet bugünkü dersimiz de
burada sona erdi
çarşamba günü
kaldığımız yerden
devam edeceğiz
yine bazen
STL algoritmalarını
göreceğiz
ondan sonra
bit set sınıfı
bit set sınıfından
sonra da
artık
operator new
ve operator delete
fonksiyonları
dinamik ömürlü
nesneler
bunların kullanılması
sonra smart pointerlar
unique ptr
ve shared ptr
big ptr sınıfları
öyle devam ediyoruz
terse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
şarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
ki